in this series I'm gonna surprise you
I'm going to strip away all the
complexity and hard craft and teach you
how to cook amazing food standing on
your head that is an amazing incredibly
tender from the kitchen novice to the
budding Chef I'm going to give you the
confidence the recipes and The Insider
knowledge to make you a much better cook
slicer out
wasting nothing
[Music]
I've been cooking in professional
kitchens for over 25 years so what
cheese is in the macaroni now I've been
taught by some of the best chefs in the
world and in turn I've taught some of
the best how much Whiskey's in there
a little bit now I'm going to show you
some simple and accessible recipes for
fantastic food that you can easily cook
at home
incredible I'll be holding you by the
hand it's getting better and better and
better teaching you everything from how
to cook with chili and spice to bacon
real fast food and my ultimate feast
recipes this is the only cooking course
you'll ever need
[Music]
Welcome to My ultimate cookery course
cooking tips information and 100 recipes
to take your life on
the frying pan is one of your best
friends it's so versatile in the kitchen
learning to use it with these is a must
and I'm going to show you how
first up my delicious pan-fried pork
chops with sweet and sour Peppers
whether it's in the restaurant or even
at home one of my golden rules for
producing fantastic food is learning to
cook with confidence this recipe is so
straightforward but tastes absolutely
amazing
panel get that nice and hot
you think of the sort of density of a
pork chop how it needs a little bit of
help
sweet and sour Peppers go brilliantly
well first slice the peppers that's the
flat side of the pepper so stand it up
trying to slice a pepper on the side is
a nightmare there's the center
start off
it's almost like sort of peeling an
orange go all the way around
and down
and look I see one
now place the pepper down three finger
rule one finger in front two behind
pinky holding it down thumb holding it
nice and flat the flatter the vegetables
the more confident you are when you
slice so
don't worry about the speed
just let the knife do the work
take your time
speed comes the most important thing
is to get your Technique right
onion
now sweet sour Peppers olive oil in
[Music]
I'm going to saute them which is just
the chef's term for shallow frying on a
high heat for maximum taste
[Music]
some salt and pepper add a tablespoon of
sugar sugar helps to break down the
peppers quicker but caramelize the
onions fry them in a frying pan perfect
that's one of the sort of basic
essential tools of any kitchen because
it's so multi-purpose great for sauteing
tossing great for cooking fresh on meat
push away and pull back push away and
pull back that hissing is something you
need to hear constantly because
the minute that's gone your peppers and
your onions start to boil and you really
want them to soak it
you now start to see it listening in a
way that it's starting to caramelize
Sugar's working beautifully
that's ready for the red wine vinegar
in
smells incredible it helps to stain the
peppers as well look at the glaze now
you can see the sugar
it's worked as magic turn down the gas
and add a couple of tablespoons of fresh
extra virgin olive oil
let them stew for two to three minutes
now I want to make the peppers nice and
light and sort of sweet aromatic just
roll the basil almost like a big cigar
slice
basil in
and then literally cook it out for 30
seconds I want them off
beautiful
okay pan back on
now the pork chops I want to make sure
they don't curl up in the pan they start
cutting up in the pan they're going to
cook unevenly a few simple cuts through
the Rhine means the chop stays flat and
Cooks evenly
Point The Knife Down
flip through just season them
beautifully
nice large shards of pepper punch that
through lightly guaranteed that's
seasoning
is going to stay there hot pan touch
garlic and touch of thyme
the garlic
take a couple of clothes
don't peel it don't chop it just knife
on
crush it
olive oil in just starting to smoke top
of the chop in
and lay away from me
it's nice
keep that heat in the pan put the garlic
in there early
a nice fragrant bunch of thyme see how
the pork is staying nice and flat turn
that over look at that beautiful
I want a little bit of thyme underneath
the
start squeezing that garlic out I want
the flavor coming out
butter in
10 slices of butter tilt the pan and
baste
so I'm sort of speeding up the cooking
process at the same time I'm keeping the
pork chop really nice and moist
and now look at the color of that butter
it's almost like sort of a nut brown
check the color on the other side
beautiful
when they're that thick
three and a half to four minutes each
side 30 seconds from now they're going
to be medium so I'm going to take them
out and let them rest
the secret to perfectly moist pork chops
is letting them rest almost as long as
they're cooked in the pan
a nice spoon
of these Peppers basil smells incredible
keep that garlic on there be generous
with that vinegar out for the peppers
because it really is incredible
do two things simple like that pork and
peppers
and your conference is going to shoot
through the roof a stunning pork chop
with sweet and sour Peppers
the frying pan is so simple but
incredibly useful with this one pan you
can make a million different dishes the
more you cook with your fine Pan the
more your confidence will grow here are
three of my favorite easy pan fried
dishes
thank you
first up pan-fried scallops with crunchy
apple salad
[Music]
frying pan smoking hot essential for
quick pan frying
add olive oil
then season scallops with salt and
pepper starting at the top put clockwise
into the pan so you know which one to
turn first
[Music]
scallops have firm white sweet flesh and
cook in minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
next salad Lamb's lettuce
sticks of Apple
[Music]
lemon zest and juice
[Applause]
[Music]
add olive oil then toss
[Music]
turn the scallops when golden going
clockwise around the pan
[Applause]
then squeeze in lemon juice and give the
pan a shake
finish with lemon zest
ready in under 10 minutes my first pan
fried dish scallops with crunchy apple
salad
my next super simple pan fried recipe is
chicken and chicory and Masala sauce
[Music]
season the chicken breasts
add to hot olive oil skin side down lay
away from you to stop it all splashing
slice chicory this versatile vegetable
can be red or white has a lovely bitter
taste and is great cooked all raw
crush a clove of garlic and add then
Springs up time
[Music]
when the chicken skin is crisp turn over
along with a chicory
for the sauce add Masala a sweet
fortified wine from Sicily
foreign
of chicken stock
to make the sauce wonderfully rich and
glossy add butter and simmer for 10
minutes
[Music]
plate up and spoon over the sauce
cooked in under 20 minutes chicken and
chicory in Masala sauce
[Music]
my final dish cooked in The Versatile
frying pan is
sea bream with tomato and Herb salsa
[Music]
fry fillets of Sebring skin side down in
hot olive oil
if they buckle up press gently down for
perfect even cooking then season
Sebring has firm white flesh perfect for
pan frying
next the salsa
heat olive oil
add half cherry tomatoes
pitted black olives
and season
[Music]
after a minute on a low heat add
coriander basil and lemon
[Music]
combine and leave to infuse
as the seed beam Cooks it goes opaque
when it's two-thirds from the top turn
over
[Music]
baste fry and it's done
[Music]
Sebring with tomato and Herb salsa ready
in under 15 minutes
one pan three simple impressive and
absolutely delicious dishes beautiful
coming up on my ultimate cookery course
along with 100 recipes to stay your life
on I'm going to give you 100 quick
cooking tips to make your life in the
kitchen easier
first up how to keep your knife Sharp
it's far harder working in the kitchen
with a blunt knife than it is with a
sharp knife the secret behind keeping a
sharp knife sharpen it before and every
time you use it first grip the steel
feel really comfortable about holding
the still imagine you're holding a
tennis racket or you're playing squash
you've got to be really comfortable with
it now 45 degrees confident grip
confident grip with a knife this is the
butt of the steel really important to
keep your fingers behind there you never
grip a steel with your fingers over that
because the knife comes back in you've
just lost a finger always grip behind
nice long strokes so we get the whole of
the blade
over Steel
stroke and we start from the bottom to
the top so there
cross there across slow Strokes over the
top of the steel and then come back
underneath
then back underneath
it is so dangerous working in the
kitchen with a blunt knife you can cause
so much damage working with a sharp
knife is 10 times quicker more efficient
now
that's ready to start chopping
stop your chopping board rocking or
slipping a great tip is to Simply wet a
kitchen cloth kitchen paper or tea towel
and place it underneath
now you can chop with confidence
my next top tip is get the most out of
your humble veg peeler
it's brilliant for slicing ultra thin
ribbons of veg perfect for Asian dishes
great for making long delicate parmesan
shavings to top soups and salads it also
makes wonderful chocolate curls
your pepper mill is more versatile than
you might think tighten the top screw to
get finely ground pepper ideal for Soups
and sauces
for general seasoning you want it medium
ground so set the screw in the middle
and loosen it right off for coarse
pepper perfect for steaks and fish
[Music]
peeling garlic for one clove simply bash
it with a back of a knife and the skin
comes off easily
for a whole head Crush separate into a
bowl
cover and shake hard for about 10
seconds
then simply pick out the peeled cloves
[Music]
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stake your life on I'll be
showing you a roast chicken recipe to
die for hold the drum and slice straight
through
but first like any good Chef I'm always
looking to get great ingredients at the
right price my shopping Mantra is simple
first rely on your senses make sure
whatever you're buying it looks smells
and really feels good and if you get the
chance taste it before you buy it second
is to recognize that knowledge is
crucial the more you know about where
your ingredients come from and how they
produce the better so ask lots of
questions and learn
you're never too old to learn from
experts and when it comes to buying
great birds one person knows what to
look for is award-winning fifth
generation Master butcher Danny lidgate
poultry is a great meet because there's
many different types of birds it's worth
tasting the variation of flavors between
different first and first is massive
turkey is a great lean meat that's
available all year round not just for
Christmas anybody who's worried about
eating fatty Meats is a really healthy
flavoursome meal okay game birds people
don't try them often enough once they're
shots they're hung up for a little while
but a few days at least it means the
meat's going to be more tender it all
adds in flavor to the birds
we've got a wood pigeon and a red leg
Partridge both really good and cook
really quickly
when you're buying a chicken some of the
things to look out for is obviously the
smell
and when you're smelling a good quality
chicken you can tell the difference the
Skin's a nice white color and it smells
like a fresh chickeny smell
when you're buying from a good butcher
you'll find you tend to get the giblets
as well which is basically the neck and
other orgas this is great for making
gravy
once you have cooked it you can use all
the off cuts for other things stir fries
curries pasta dishes save the bones use
the bones for stocks and soups a really
packed full of flavor
and remember there are lots of different
breeds of chicken all have different
characteristics and flavors so shop
around and find the ones you love here
are three of my all-time favorites
the label onglay these come from an old
British breed they've got smaller
breasts but the meat's delicious
the black leg a fantastic French variety
succulent with bags of flavor and really
meaty thighs
and the police this is the Rolls-Royce
of chickens Rich gamey and delicious one
for special occasions
I think people should maybe try and buy
Less meat but aim for the best quality
you're only going to get out what you
put in by putting the best quality into
a dish you're going to get the best
results
no matter how season the chef you are
there are always new ingredients and
recipes to get fired up about
so if a tidal recipe is getting you down
spice it up with fresh ideas and flavors
this recipe is an old classic roast
chicken but with a simple twist it takes
on a new life and is guaranteed to
impress
one of the things I love about cooking
and that keeps me excited after 25 years
behind the stove is that there's always
something new to learn every day new
ingredients new techniques and new
cuisines
start off with the stuffing it's amazing
how exciting a stuffed roast chicken can
be because it keeps the chicken
incredibly moist and gives a delicious
texture inside the bird I'm going to
start off with cured chorizo this is a
traditional Spanish sausage and it's
garlicky spicy incredibly meaty
that gives a little bit of sort of
richness to the stuffing get a freezer
in
start cooking that down and getting all
those oils out
little touch the olive oil in there to
get it going right onions
chopped
add the onions to the chorizo and in a
matter of seconds they'll change color
as they soak up all the flavor that
lovely spiciness has been stolen from
that sausage and now the onions smell
incredible
garlic
garlic in fresh thyme just hold it down
and put your fingers on there and it's a
really nice way of taking off all those
nice fragrant little time flowers
you can hear it cracking in the
background
these are cannellini beans they're waxy
very soft and so delicious but very
dense but for stuffing they're so robust
nothing breaks down drain them off
in
they're going to take on all that juice
as well from this freezer I'm going to
season them now because they're very
dense so it needs some help
and that looks like it's a dish on its
own good enough to eat now
I want to sweeten things up a little bit
Tomatoes half dried
in
that sweetens up
the stuffing
beautiful
the stuffing's ready look at the color
everything
Spanish it looks delicious now
stuffing the chicken I like taking off
these little knuckles
as the chicken Cooks the skin stretches
over the bone you can get a really nice
drum and take off those little wing tips
as well
salt pepper
so important
now you're stuffing I want to go right
inside the chicken
push it down this really helps to cook
the bird evenly because you're pushing
out all the empty spaces in the carcass
and take a nice large Lemon push the
lemon in
pick up the parcel's nose pull the skin
over olive oil on top
sauce
pepper
a teaspoon of paprika
sprinkle it on and then get your hands
and sort of rub that in and see what the
paprika's doing to the chicken putting
this like sweet spicy marinade it's not
even roasted yet but it looks delicious
[Music]
400 ml white wine same quantity of water
that helps the chicken to steam
Chicken in
be generous with the time Sprigs
make sure the fall is folded tightly
around the roasting tray so the chicken
steams in the oven keeping it moist and
juicy
into the oven
[Music]
cook for one hour at 180 degrees with a
foil on nice take it out and remove the
full lid then give it another 30 minutes
to crisp up that skin
look at that
so important to make sure you take that
tinfoil off with half an hour to go
beautiful
Pierce that open
squeeze it in that delicious gravy mix
that into the tray
sieve that
that's a really nice fragrant lemony
spiced roasting juices to finish
before we cut up the chicken take out
amazing stuffing
[Music]
incredible I'd have that with chicken
over potatoes any day and then just get
your chicken roasting juices
now
cut the chicken up
hold the drum
and slice straight through
and there's that wonderful drum and the
thigh through the wishbone
off
slice with the point at an angle so you
can see the texture
of that amazing roast chicken
take my cooking juices I just want to
give a nice sort of lemony flavor
all over my chicken and there you go
a delicious very Charming stuffed roast
chicken
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to save your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
in this series I'm going to surprise you
I'm going to strip away all the
complexity and hard craft and teach you
how to cook amazing food standing on
your head that is amazing incredibly
tender from the kitchen novice to the
budding Chef I'm going to give you the
confidence the recipes and The Insider
knowledge to make you a much better cook
slice around
wasting nothing
I made my name cooking some of the
world's most demanding kitchens
service yeah in my restaurants I expect
Perfection every player has to be worthy
of a Michelin star and every time you
make it yeah every day changes now I'm
going to show you some simple and
accessible recipes for fantastic food
that you can cook easily at home
incredible I'll be holding by the hand
it's getting better and better and
better
do everything from how to cook on a
budget to bacon real fast food and my
ultimate feast recipes this is the only
cookery course you'll ever need
[Music]
Welcome to My ultimate cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to take your life on right
this is my guide to cooking with spice
adding big gutsy flavors using spices at
the beginning of cooking and then simply
letting the dish slow cook is a
brilliant way of getting maximum flavor
with minimum effort
my first recipe melts in the mouth and
because the oven does most of the work
it's a cinch to make slow cooked fiery
lamb cooking's all about being bold and
adventurous and this dish is exciting
because it's slowly cooked and the
longer it Cooks the more flavor
something it becomes
marinating the lamb first chilies we're
going to use a mixture of red and green
take off the tops
and just slice
in
garlic
crushed
don't worry about chopping these ultra
fine just get it in there cooking for up
to three hours
everything sort of Blends and almost
sort of
purees itself together
smoke paprika goes brilliantly well with
the chilies two teaspoons in a touch of
dried oregano
some little cumin seeds the blend and
the fragrance that they give out is
extraordinary they release a little oil
as well and helps to tenderize the lamb
touch of salt
pepper
cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamb
olive oil
just a tablespoon and the olive oil
helps to sort of stick all those
wonderful spices to the lamb Chomp in
just start really rubbing at this stage
you can leave the lamb to marinade for
anything from half an hour to overnight
allowing the spices to really penetrate
the meat giving amazing results when you
tuck in delicious vegetables carrots and
onions and that's it sliced
cigarette slicing vegetables for
braising is not getting too thin you
slice the onions too thin they burn
you've got that horrible Char taste on
that slow braised braising it's just a
chef's term that means cooking in liquid
on a low heat making the meat incredibly
moist and beautifully tender so the
secret of braising is having a really
nice thick
durable pan
get that nice and hot
Touch of olive oil
lemon hold the bone because you're in
control then into the pan
you want that white fat to start
rendering so it'll add more fat
therefore making it a lot more
flavoursome as it braises
chillers cinnamon
in mix that up
and don't be scared you're not burning
this you're sort of searing the lamb
shanks and this is the important part
right at the very beginning we're going
to color on the lamb which washes off as
it braises in the oven so be generous
with that color
vegetables in
wow and then a couple of Baileys
so now you lift the lamb up
and get the lamb
sat on top of the vegetables
now the glaze the pan with red wine
the glazing means that you're cleaning
the bottom of the pan and you're getting
that amazing flavor washed off and
lifted up into that sauce it can really
transform that dish always delays then
bring it to the boil and cook for about
10 minutes to reduce the wines reduced
down by half now for the stock
bring that stock back up to the ball and
then into the oven now don't cover it
when you cover it all the condensation
comes off the lid your lamb becomes gray
all this effort and that exciting spice
gets washed away no lid and in the oven
for three hours
a slow cook on a low heat of 160 degrees
gives the spices time to work and
transform the meat so it's mouth-waterly
tender now
look at those
out on to a plate you can just see that
meat sliding down
juicy and creamy tender grab it by the
the shank rolling around that rich
delicious sauce
look at that
and get your sauce
beautiful let's get some mint don't chop
it just pick that fresh mint and let it
snow and there you go a very spicy
delicious melting in the mouth lamb
shank amazing
to get the most out of your spices
there's only one piece of kit that you
need pestle and water I mean they look
fantastic and it's essential for any
good kitchen these things are so
versatile these ancient kitchen tools
are perfect for everything from pestos
to dressings and cost them around 15
quid
use the grind spices and you'll max out
on Flavor get perfect textures and
always be totally in control make sure
you've got a nice large circumference of
the bowl
so you can grind away the heavier the
more durable they are the more
confidence it gives you when you're
pounding and there's almost a way of
confirming homemade hand pounded
grab yourself a pestle and mortar and
soon you'll be spicing with ease
is our brilliant way to add an extra
layer and a depth of complexity to any
dish learning to use them properly will
really improve your cooking here are
three more of my super simple spice
recipes to get you going
[Music]
first up a very easy chili and spiced
white bait
start with the spice coating
toast Szechuan peppercorns and coriander
seeds in a hot dry pan to release their
flavors
add chili flakes and grind the pestle
and water to make a fiery fine powder
combined with plain flour season and mix
[Music]
add olive oil to a hot pan
coat white bait in the spicy flour mix
then fry
white bait are an oily fish that are
healthy delicious and cooking minutes
once golden they're done
fantastic with garlic mayonnaise or a
simple squeeze of lemon
[Music]
ready in under 10 minutes chili and
spiced white bait and easy simple spicy
dish
[Music]
my next amazingly aromatic recipe is
roasted squash hummus
[Music]
start with my take on razal hanud a
classic Moroccan spice blend in a dry
pan toast Cinnamon cloves coriander
fenugreek and fennel seeds
then add mustard seeds and cumin
when the seeds start to pop they're
ready
add paprika and grind into a fine powder
for the hummus peel and chop butternut
squash
put on a baking tray and add garlic
simply bashed and chopped Ginger
drizzle with olive oil season and
sprinkle over the spice mix
then roast in a hot oven for half an
hour until soft
allowed to cool and place in a blender
a tahini a Nutty paste made from sesame
seeds cooked chickpeas a dash of lemon
juice and a drizzle of olive oil
flits into a luxuriously creamy and
textured
spices toasted for maximum flavor
amazing roasted squash hummus
my final deliciously spicy dishes
curry spice sweet corn soup
[Music]
first The Fragrant curry paste
roast coriander and cumin seeds until
aromatic
then grind add in crushed garlic chili
powder turmeric and finely chopped
Ginger
[Music]
bring together with olive oil to form a
thick paste
for the soup fry finely chopped onions
in olive oil
[Music]
add the curry paste and cook to release
the flavors
add cubed potatoes
chicken stock
and season
when the potato has softened stir in
creamed corn
then add whole sweet corn kernels with
some of the juices
and transfer to a blender and Blitz
until smooth
for texture add more whole sweet corn
[Music]
is ready to serve
[Music]
wonderfully satisfying colored spice
sweet corn soup that packs an amazingly
aromatic punch
three more stunning recipes that make
cooking with spice simple
incredible
[Music]
this is my guide to cooking with spice
next up my shopping guide to buying
spices
[Music]
when I buy my spice I only want the best
and it always pays to get expert advice
Burger has been selling every spice
Under the Sun in London's Notting Hill
for over 20 years so she really knows
what she's talking about I love spices
to smell all the texture to color spices
are so versatile something very very
simple can be really transformed into
something really delicious with
thousands of aromatic ingredients on a
shelf if it smells good she sells it if
you're buying spices buy them whole then
you can try roast them crying the men
you need them and then they will release
the essential oils whole spices you can
keep for years give them a good bushing
wine bottle with your rolling pin or
whatever and you see there is still
Aroma and you can taste it you smell it
then it's fine
there's four main spices one is sweet
one is sour one is bitter and one is hot
this is cinnamon and that is really a
great example of a sweet spice when you
buy a cinnamon quill like this you have
to check that you have loads of
different layers in here then you can
either grind this or you'd break a piece
off I mean this doesn't smell of
anything now
but if you roll it in your hand just
quickly like this
and then you smell it again this is just
unbelievable if you have spaghetti
bolognese put a pinch of cinnamon in it
to bring out the flavor
this is one of those
really special spices sour like a lemon
but it has a salty aftertaste I use this
anywhere for marinades to salad you
haven't left unless you tried it a great
example for a bitter spice would
actually be a turmeric this is actually
a root it grows in the ground like
ginger use it very very sparingly about
that much well actually color you a
curry or a rice dish wonderful yellow
watch your fingers you get really yellow
fingers from it and then we come to the
hot spices one spice that I couldn't
miss and that is Hungarian paprika
paprika is the powdery form of a bell
pepper what makes the Hungarian paprika
different is that they actually grow it
in Vineyards it's sort of between the
vines it has a sweetness and it has a
sharpness to it I have it in ice cream I
have it on fish I have it everywhere
burger spot on about the power of spices
to transform dishes where there's Savory
or sweet here's my quick guide to the
spices I use most
spice I couldn't do without always buy a
whole and grind yourself so you get the
freshest flavor cardamom these pods come
in green or black types and have a
fantastic Spicy Sweet Taste brilliant
for everything from curries to rice
dishes and puddings
coriander these citrusy seeds are
perfect whole in pickles or grind to use
in fragrant stews and soups
cumin a Savory Spice that's pungent and
nutty it's great in marinade for
delicious Meat and Fish
then cinnamon sweetly fragrant and great
with apples or in cakes
and Nutmeg warm and spicy it's delicious
in a vegetable sauce finely saffron
these sweet strands Infuse a brilliant
bright red color and are great in
risottos and even though it's more
expensive than gold a pinch goes a long
long way store your spices properly and
they'll last for years you keep it
airtight in a tin or in a glass chair in
your cupboard
don't be scared of spices like an
aftershave or a perfume you have to
select it yourself it has to fit in with
your taste and with your kitchen
supermarkets and good local shops sell
an amazing array of different spices so
there's no excuse for not being
adventurous be bold find what you like
and spice up your cooking
like all chefs I love the challenge of
transforming classic recipes giving them
a new twist to make them modern and
vibrant
to keep old dishes fresh and exciting
it's great to get spicy
my next recipe is a time-honored British
classic but with addition of spices it's
given a new lease of Life fragrant spice
rice pudding I love cooking with spices
but you don't have to just cook Savory
dishes using aromatics and spices across
desserts takes your puddings to a
completely different level
[Music]
first off our spices this is a fresh
vanilla pod fragrant and packed full of
flavor use the back of the knife and
flatten it that removes all those little
seeds off the skin of the vanilla pod
take your knife slice down the middle
and then when you open that up the smell
is incredible take the tip of the knife
and you scrape inside and look
at all those seeds dying to come out
that is incredible there are thousands
of seeds still ingrained to the Pod so
put them in to the casserole cardamom
powerful spicy
take two little pods place your knife on
top
lightly crack them cracking the cardamom
pods helps release all the amazing
flavor cloves because of that kind of
aniseed flavor with a lot of depth
one two three cinnamon stick
snap and in
just smelling that level of fragrance
you can imagine what the rice pudding is
in the taste of turn on the heat lightly
toast those spices just a couple of
seconds and what's going to happen is
just going to sort of enhance those
spices in a way that it just draws out
an even more powerful fragrance coconut
milk in
sugar
two tablespoons
milk
and then a couple of tablespoons of
cream
bring it slowly to the boil to allow the
flavors to infuse and this rice pudding
reminds me of my time in India where I
got really into that chai tea fragrance
because it was just so delicious and so
comforting
take a lime
in the lime just cuts through the
richness of the coconut gives it that
nice little bit of acidity goes
fantastically well with the cinnamon and
that fresh vanilla
nice have a taste
now let's come up to the boil give it a
nice little clean around the outside
and in with the rice
use 200 grams of pudding rice don't wash
it beforehand because the starch helps
thicken the rice pudding in the oven
and just turn that down to a light
simmer and the pudding rice starts to
open up and it absorbs all that coconut
vanilla
cardamom clove and cinnamon bring it to
the ball gently and cook it out three to
five minutes
bullying it rapidly the rice opens up
and it goes into mush I want to keep
that nice texture of that sort of
fragrant rice pudding on a gentle simmer
next a little luxury
I'm going to show you how I take this
simple delicious aromatic rice pudding
to a completely different level here's
what I do take
two egg yolks separating them
and give that a really nice whisk
two nice tablespoons of mascarpone
cheese
we started into the egg yolks
so it's nice and smooth
it's almost like finishing the rice
pudding in a delicious custard turn off
the gas add that
into the rice pudding what happens it
starts to enrich and really thicken this
rice pudding and takes it to a
completely different level
the rice is still not cooked started to
go nice and soft you can just see how
it's opening up
but looks like Rich aromatic lava
bubbling away
finally Great Mall Citrus zest the lime
on top
roasted caramelized lime zest on top of
a rice pudding
is phenomenal
then put it in the oven for 15 minutes
at 200 degrees to finish cooking the
rice and develop the intensely aromatic
flavors
look at that
an incredibly fragrant rice pudding how
beautiful does that look
spices are a brilliant way of helping
classic dishes come alive
I'll guarantee you'll never ever have
had a rice pudding like this before
next my tricks of the trays and kitchen
tips
first how to zest the lemon
the important part is not to zest any of
the pith watch the following technique
and I'll show you how
we've got these original graters really
important when we use this which is the
fine zester not the big rough one not
the one for slicing and not the other
one for grating this little one here
onto a plate because it's always easier
to lift off on the plate than it is the
board and the most important thing about
zesting a lemon is nice long strokes but
twisting the lemon round every time we
go down we twist
same with the orange and same with the
lime
tap
if you go too far
let me just show you look we've got that
white bitter pith that destroys the
wonderful
zesty flavor and look that's what we're
looking for there this really nice
vibrant lemon zest delicious
garlic is a key ingredient in so many
spicy dishes my tip for finely chopping
and mincing is add a pinch of salt for
abrasion which helps break the fibers of
the garlic down for a much better result
for getting the most out of root Ginger
simply remove the skin using a teaspoon
it's easier than using a knife and you
can get around the tricky bits or just
keep the skin on and give it a good wash
never throw out vanilla pods there's a
ton of flavor left in the skin stick
inside jars of sugar and leave to infuse
great to sprinkle on cakes biscuits or
porridge
when grinding up spices if you have any
left over you can store in an airtight
jar for up to two months great for a
spicy kick to have at your fingertips
foreign
My ultimate cookery course crammed with
key lessons
up tips and 100 recipes to stay your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better Chef many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking